à
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président ce sujet
crucial donc je me permets de revenir
sur la coque 26 qui se tient cette
semaine à glasgow
comme l'a rappelé l'éminent président
longeau la france s'est fixé il ya cinq
ans lors des accords de paris des
objectifs ambitieux
mais rappelez-vous ici même dans cette
assemblée il ya moins d'un an nous avons
tenu un débat sur un risque de black out
énergétique
on ferme fessenheim et on achète en
allemagne de l'énergie fabriqués dans
les conditions que l'on sait qu'en est
il cette année
comment comptez vous tenir les objectifs
face au défi climatique et permettent
aux français de connaître des hivers
moins chaotique
j'ai écouté avec attention la lecture de
vos fiches même le ministre
non mais chacun sait vos tergiversations
sur le nucléaire sa salle moyens au
moins des clercs alors que c'est un
atout pour notre pays vous avez le
nucléaire honteux et gris à vouloir se
passer du nucléaire
on va finir par éteindre toutes les
lumières et
vous voulez 100 % de véhicules
électriques mais vous voulez vous passer
de la principale source d'électricité
et ce ne sont pas votre plein
d'éoliennes qui souffriront la france
des campagnes leur dit non la france des
campagnes comme la france des villes
peine à se chauffer
la france des campagnes comme la france
des villes peine à se chauffer la france
des campagnes peine à rouler pour
travailler seule solution de mobilité
pour sortir de l'impasse
l'énergie pour tous passent pas une
baisse massive des taxes et l'état y
gagnera à court terme car le pouvoir
d'achat dégagé sera source de
consommation et ainsi de tvr encaissé
alors cohérence est beaucoup plus en
seraient les bienvenues pour permettre
aux français d hiver moins tendu je vous
remercie monsieur le président
[Musique]